in CBS News senior international
security analyst Fran Townsend is a
former homeland security advisor to
President George W Bush good morning
good morning Charlie the testing of an
ICBM if successful is a critical
decision point for the president that's
right charlie and I think look the good
news is the most recent missile test
failed but they've made significant
progress and so when the president says
others have been outplayed I think what
he's talking about is both the
development that we've seen in the
missile program and the the nuclear test
the underground nuclear test that we've
seen and he's right it is very
concerning the amount of progress we've
seen over the last 12 years in the North
Korean program is this thing ratcheting
up so intensely that somebody could make
a mistake and we're all yeah i wor I
don't worry about the u.s.
miscalculating I do worry about Kim
jong-un miscalculating the rhetoric look
I don't think anybody wants to see that
sort of an escalation and I think Mike
Pence's statements this morning in Japan
signal we're not looking to make a first
strike but we also won't sit idly by
China's got this huge trade relationship
China has real ability to sort of impede
the supply chain into North Korea there
are banks there are businesses so China
really does have tremendous leverage and
the question is can we bring them to a
point where they'll use it that's the
question I mean Jerry Simon The Wall
Street Journal raises this today which
is that the Chinese still oppose the Fed
missile defense system in South Korea
well let's remember what China's
strategic interest is here right they
don't want to see chaos in North Korea
but they also are not fans of a unified
Korean Peninsula because what they don't
want to see is US military forces on
their border in a unified Korea and so
we have to understand what each
country's strategic interest is but try
to play that to our best advantage
France someone who knows how these type
of conversations go there's a lot of
tough talk on both sides what do you
think is going on behind the scenes well
no question look you see the diplomatic
effort playing out between the president
president Trump and president G but
there's we also ought to expect there's
covert and clandestine
tivity on both sides we know that North
Korea's got cyber ability and we know
the United States does as well as
electronic warfare capability and so
while we don't understand the details of
that behind the scenes those sorts of
plays are being made to try and
influence the way people any evidence
that the Chinese are changing just a bit
well we saw them turn back the cold but
you know as we heard from Margaret
trades up 40% and so we have to watch
for you know the president has said
maybe in today's interview maybe they
can't do much I don't buy that I think
the Chinese have tremendous leverage on
trade diplomacy sanctions there's all
sorts of things they can do and we
better see that start happening pretty
quickly here and the president said
you'll make a deal by softening up on
trade if they'll do something with North
Korea that's right but we ought to see
overt and real definite signs of Chinese
activity before he does that Fran
Townsend always good to have you here
thank you